I believe that negativity is better at  marketing than positivity I believe that  the positive people on Earth are content  and play insular with their family I  believe the negative people on Earth are  not content and are screaming out of  their [ __ ] mouths at the highest  levels and are sucking people in I  believe that the people in this room who  are happy who are Joy who have love in  their soul have a responsibility to be  louder and so what I can tell you is I  want to be the best marketer in the  world I really want to explain to people  that if you're happy consider sharing  that a little bit more and so I just  want people to pick practical optimism  versus default cynicism and so I will  Market that [ __ ] until the day I [ __ ]  die